bonjour jean marc sylvestre alors ses
résultats d'entreprises françaises au
premier sommet c'est un désastre
whittier d'un visage l'état des lieux et
des tas de trucs bien tout simplement
parce que l'essentiel de l'activité
s'est arrêtée un star était complètement
pendant deux mois
elle a du mal aujourd'hui à redémarrer
début mars souvenez vous touche
fonctionner à peu près correctement avec
une situation de l'emploi qui était
d'ailleurs assez bonne partout dans le
monde notamment en occident fin mars des
plus beaux fleurons se sont arrêtés
leurs dirigeants se sont mis à appeler
tous l'état au secours au secours parce
que leur trésorerie est évident parce
que leur marché était vive les magasins
étaient vides et les usines ne tournent
et par conséquent au deuxième trimestre
de l'année c'est à dire si on fait avril
mai et juin bat le pibe de la france
s'est effondré écoutez bien de 13,4 pour
cent le bip c'est l'ensemble des
richesses que l'on créait 13,4 pour cent
en moins ça ne s'est jamais vu dans
l'histoire économique
ça représente plus de 340 milliards
d'euros perdus envolés en fumée comme ça
plus d'un million d'emplois détruits au
coeur de la tempête disons fin avril
bien l'activité s'était effondré de 50 %
alors depuis le déconfinement ça reprend
1 mais ça reprend quand même très
doucement cette situation a été partagé
par la plupart des pays européens
occidentaux
il y en a pas un qui peut aider l'autre
en attendant bien les entreprises elles
font le bilan de ce qui s'est passé la
plupart ont perdu elle entre 50 et 100%
de leur marché vous avez raison toutes
les industries touristiques ont touché
le fond le groupe accor qui est le
troisième groupe mondial en hôtellerie
groupe français va publier ses résultats
demain matin
il n'a fait aucun chiffre d'affaires le
club med pierre et vacances sont à peu
près dans la même situation la plupart
des grands hôtels resteront fermés
jusqu'à la fin de l'année notamment à
paris des compagnies aériennes vous le
disais l'aéronautique c'est également
désastreux les groupes automobiles eux
n'ont pas vendu une seule voiture
pendant deux mois c'est vous dire si de
bilan sont mauvais alors que ça s'en
sort parce que les psa et fait d'énormes
efforts de productivité de compétitivité
auparavant avec des choix stratégiques
de modèles qui ont plutôt continué de
marché qui ont repris très vite donc ça
limite les dégâts
mme ernoult révèle une perte colossale
de 7 milliards alors l'agroalimentaire
s'en sortent plutôt bien c'est peut-être
un des seuls secteurs à s'en sortir bien
sûr parce qu'il a fallu se nourrir et
que les grands distributeurs ont fait un
certain nombre d'efforts notamment avec
la livraison à domicile toutes les
industries digital aussi et on attend on
attend un peu d'inquiétude le résultat
des banques mais voyez-vous les banques
notamment les banques françaises ont des
contrats de gestion qui les ont sans
doute protégé on leur a reproché
d'ailleurs d'être trop prudente et bien
maintenant cette prudence leur sert
parce qu'elles sont plutôt solides mais
le système bancaire a l'immense avantage
d'avoir trouver de la liquidité auprès
de la bce la banque centrale européenne
a mis le système bancaire européen sous
perfusion c'est la bce qui garantit
l'équilibré financier du système
européen
merci madame lagarde alors comment ça ta
situation va-t-elle à 100 redresse
vous savez a priori la situation des
entreprises pourraient se redresser
assez rapidement parce que le système a
été beaucoup aidé et le système n'a pas
perdu des actifs matériels on n'a pas
détruit des usines on n'a pas détruit
d'entreprise tout fonctionne tout s'est
arrêté
on a perdu certes 340 milliards de
valeur d'activité mais l'état les
banques la banque centrale européenne la
commission européenne ont remis plus de
340 milliards dans le jeu donc ça
devrait repartir les consommateurs ont
de l'argent de l'epagne ça a été la
vertu de deux du chômage partiel
les entreprises ont pu s'endetter à des
conditions responsable c'est le résultat
des pg e les plans garanties par l'état
on a mis le pays en coma artificiel mais
au réveil avait bien il devrait
retrouver sa capacité cela dit on a deux
problèmes le problème c'est qu'on
découvre qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qu'on appelle les entourent ils ont mis
en france les entreprises qui était
malade avant donc elles sont encore plus
mal après est permis ces entreprises là
vous avez des grosses et les normes kit
auto parts au bout air france étaient
balade bien avant l'arrivée du
coronavirus renault aussi et puis il ya
un deuxième problème c'est que le
redémarrage dépend essentiellement du
retour de la confiance c'est
indépendante du venus
ça dépend de la façon dont on va se
protéger c'est bien pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on
bien sûr la stratégie d'eads et des
masques historique que vous avez fait
inquiétant mais il est malheureusement
real il faut se protéger
je crois malheureusement qu'il va
falloir continuer de se protéger et à
attendre le vaccin aux meilleurs des cas
dans le grenier aux chaînes
merci à vous jean marc sylvestre âge
rappelle que vous êtes un journaliste
éditorialiste économique